[Música]
el día del maestro publicaron una nota
sobre el proyecto educativo que dirijo
yo soy directora de una escuela que
trabaja en líneas de inclusión fue
inevitable leer los comentarios que se
generaron en las redes en relación a
esta nota pero uno llamó particularmente
mi atención decía algo así como que era
un excelente proyecto social pero no
académico
por qué
porque trabajamos con una población
atravesada por la pobreza y por la
discapacidad cuál es el problema la
representación social de la educación
inclusiva menos recursos menos
posibilidades menos capacidades menos
contenidos entonces es imposible llegar
a la excelencia educativa para cambiar
la representación que tenemos como
sociedad de las escuelas que trabajamos
en este contexto tenemos que empezar por
la escuela haciendo visible a esos otros
que alguna vez la escuela no dio
respuesta para poder tener una mirada
diferente para poder valorar el esfuerzo
que se hacen dentro de estas escuelas
para que todos puedan aprender
camine dos cuadras abrazada un alumno
que tenía su navaja y no la dejaba
soporte los insultos de los vecinos del
barrio que me culpaba por no entregarlo
a la policía no es la escuela la que
tiene que cambiar la navaja por la
lapicera pero cuál es la representación
de la lapicera la lapicera que le
permita ser dueña de su destino de
escribir su propia historia de no estar
obligado a reproducir historia de vida
la escuela inclusiva la escuela que
trabaja en la pobreza no reproduce
pobreza y en relación a la discapacidad
porque también trabajamos con personas
con discapacidad y bueno pero si hacen
adecuaciones curriculares vacían de
contenidos es un como si la escuela no
es un club la escuela tiene que enseñar
a aprender
entro valentín con síndrome de dawn hoy
está ingresando de la escuela y el
comentario es viste que todas las
personas con síndrome de down son
amorosas te dan besitos es re lindo
trabajar con chicos con síndrome de dawn
los eternos niños eso es una
representación no todos te dan besitos
valen entro y a las dos semanas el
escándalo cuando culo y teta se le
atravesaba por el camino el tipo metía
mano desesperado las chicas reclamaban
que pudiéramos hacer una intervención
llamamos a la familia y nos dijeron que
lo estaban trabajando con el psicólogo
llamamos al psicólogo y el psicólogo me
dijo
valentín tiene síndrome de down
está tomado por su sexualidad
no tiene filtro
exactamente ese es el problema y que
hacemos lo estamos trabajando y claro no
hay psicólogo que te solucione el
problema
en una visita verdad sino iríamos todos
a ese psicólogo y no gastaríamos tanta
plata en terapia así que tenía que dar
una respuesta en las chicas entré al
aula y les dije chicas valentín tiene el
síndrome de down
está tomado por su sexualidad
no tiene filtros y ellas me miraron y le
dije mira él también te quiere tocar
pero lo reprime ballet no y entonces lo
están trabajando viendo que no había
solución al problema por lo menos
inmediato ellas encontraron la solución
y caminaron así
para evitar el manoseo
para valentín entonces no había límites
fue por todas fue por el patio hasta que
tocó a la novia de un chico de quinto
del barrio
fiesta
no le pegó porque cuando vos trabajás en
inclusión se crea cultura escolar
inclusiva pero valentín dicen los
preceptores no toco el piso porque lo
llevó del brazo lo llevo a la dirección
me golpeó la puerta porque el educado la
abrió porque era importante y me dijo
silvana hacia algo con él porque tendrá
síndrome de down pero boludo no es
entonces aprendí una gran lección yo que
vivo hablando de inclusión aprendí de un
compañero de ballet que estaba comprando
la representación del eterno niño del
que no entiende en el que está tomado
por su sexualidad y no puede vale y
necesitaba un límite y como escuela
pusimos el límite el límite y la sanción
en una escuela como la nuestra no es
dejar ni un minuto un chico en la calle
porque si lo dejas en la calle lo perder
son más horas dentro de la escuela y en
una semana
valentín dejó de tocar a las chicas
quiere decir que la pasó bomba hasta que
le pusimos el límite él jugó con la
representación que nosotros compramos la
oportunidad que te da la escuela es
cambiar esta representación y es más la
escuela inclusiva tiene que permitir de
estar con todos pero también encontrarte
en un espejo
llegar al patio y también poder verte en
un espejo otro valen de segundo año
franco de tercer año sentados en mi
dirección valen me dice sabe silvana yo
no tengo amigos en esta escuela y yo le
respondí qué mal que estamos haciendo
las cosas en rumanía qué voz esta altura
del año y no tenéis amigos y él me dice
no no es rumanía yo le tengo fobia a los
chicos de mi edad franco que estaba
escuchando le dijo no tendrá síndrome de
asperger como yo porque a mí me pasa lo
mismo
valentina abrió los ojos así y le dice a
ver
yo no entiendo los chistes de mis
compañeros y franco le dijo yo tampoco
pero aprendí a reírme así logras
pertenecer lo importante de compartir
los códigos que fue aprendiendo uno y
transmitiéndole al otro la escuela
inclusiva es una escuela que aloja pero
es una escuela exigente una escuela que
hace que le pase la escuela al alumno
que le pase por el cuerpo que lo
empodera que le permite insertarse en
sociedad y no sólo eso sino y volviendo
a la idea de ser dueños de su destino
poder elegir autovalimiento autonomía
poder elegir si quiero trabajar y si
quiero estudiar y tener las herramientas
para estudiar es una escuela exigente
porque exige lo mejor de cada uno de los
alumnos entendemos que todos los chicos
pueden aprender que lo que son capaces
de aprender y como escuela el objetivo
es hacer que todos sean capaces
de aprender lo máximo que puede aprender
sin poner nosotros el techo y para
cerrar les cuento valen aprendió de
francos cuando estaban cerrando el
proyecto de educación física los
profesores invitaron a una pateada no me
eligieron cerrar así comiendo juntos
niko
que está en primer año empieza a
protestar dice yo no quiero estar acá a
mí me gustaría estar cuando la playa no
me interesa estar con otros no me
interesa compartir este momento y valen
despacito le dice a la profesora yo
también pienso lo mismo
creo que aprendí que acá tengo otra
oportunidad que esto a mí me hace bien
ella también va a aprender
eso es lo que puede una escuela
inclusiva si eso no es un proyecto
educativo
la escuela no es un club menos por menos
no es más gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]